premier devenir une dernière fois avec
nous opposer au revoir le bonheur est un
film sur la famille ou quatre fils vive
le décès de leur père j'ai l'impression
que c'est un film qui fait du bien je
fais musou on sait ce qu'ils apportent
sur un apport de la douceur ya pas la
délicatesse de la bigue la bienveillance
on n'amène pas monsieur côté tandis que
l'heure est au recueillement les quatre
orphelins se rend dans la maison
familiale située aux îles de la
madeleine pour rendre un hommage au père
disparu il y aura des mésententes entre
ces quatre personnages qui sont des
archétypes il y a l'épicurien le
nostalgique l'intellectuel et l'homme
d'affaires sans scrupules pour moi le
personnage que je des feuilles ce point
ce parking c'est juste qu ils regardent
les affaires sans émotion
oui
voilà
encore raté l'avion pour avoir le
bonheur est réalisé par ken scott qui
avait aussi fait le film starbuck est
signé le scénario de la grande séduction
qui se déroulait sur la côte nord pour
son dernier film la pandémie a obligé
ken scott à cette tournée valises et de
la madeleine on devrait tourner ailleurs
au au départ c'était prévu qu'on allait
tourner en provence ensuite ça a été la
vanne mais à cause de la pandémie on
pouvait plus de tournées à l'extérieur
du pays alors il a fallu ajuster a pas
toujours dit que la famille ses deux
plus grandes richesses magnifiques
cartes postales des îles de la madeleine
ou revoir le bonheur met en scène une
distribution étincelante et inspiré par
le vent du large on restait ensemble par
l'histoire et dès cette semaine même aux
il
nous est donc si t'as pas le choix de
t'imprégner un de la vie la botte de
comprendre un petit peu plus ce qu'ils
vivent on n'a pas eu le choix que de
devenir une espèce de symbiose ensemble
la machine oui bruxelles agen à cheval
entre le drame la comédie et la
mélancolique au revoir le bonheur
souffre toutefois d'un scénario
prévisible et léger on est bien loin de
la grande séduction
oui même radio canada montréal